all right what are you going real
believable finally something we can all
agree on sure Ash Ketchum from Pokémon
is in a
coma and I believe that whole we stoed
down to like Creepy Pasta levels what
what do you mean this is like a this is
he is in a theory like I don't think the
Creator even knows this himself but Ash
catam is in a coma okay okay this is my
theory all right sure I mean this would
be very easy to debunk all we have to do
is ask Satoshi Tajiri you can't ask him
why uh
exist well I saw him at dinner one time
and I asked him and he was like I fun
fact I did part of the conspiracy I did
actually see him and he was like yeah
Connor he's in a com buddy he English is
very good uh I I asked him Japanese
actually oh um so so what's this Theory
Ash catch him in a cuz I have heard of
this before but I don't know the details
number one Ash why is he Forever Young
why can he not H cuz he's not real what
do you mean he what are you saying
fictional character what you mean that
that's Detective Conan the same thing as
well well he's he's racist or he
[Music]
actually I don't remember that episode
it was a
different let's you remember the Conan
being raciste that's a Mandela effect
I'm remembering that one right yeah he
hates foreigners actually yeah uh so you
know obviously Ash catch him never Ages
which sure what the [__] going on
there that's a bit sus um you know uh
the Pokémon world is seen as an
idealized version of reality where
children can travel the world safely and
live out Adventures which could be a
manifestation of a child's dream think
about it right we you know if this was
the real world I don't think we'd be
letting [__] 12-year-olds run around
with [__] dangerous animals that
shoot laser beams that is true so I
think this is Ash ketchum's idealized up
in the yeah because like the world of
Pokemon from any responsible adult
shouldn't exist I have I have a I have a
piece of evidence that also proves that
because in episodes of Pokémon if you
notice you know look at the details
right of course there are wild Pokémon
out and about but they're also just like
regular ass Birds right that are not
Pokémon so it's like so are Pokémon
animals are they yeah so so you know and
um there are some there are some scenes
where it's just like a regular like fish
or like a regular like just bird that is
not a Pokémon yeah right and so what
this is this is Ash's
subconscious blending his reality
understanding of life before he got in
the coma think look look at that look at
that that's regular fish none of those
are Pokemon and what that is that is Ash
ketchum's previous life his memories are
seeping into this he's adding Pokemon
onto the real world so yeah so it's his
He is building the world from his
knowledge right cuz the world is pretty
normal there's no it's a pretty normal
world there's normal animals just so
happens that there's then Pokémon on top
which is like a different class and
because you know you could say yeah it's
a children's show but Ash's view of this
world and the world that way it's it's
too childlike right why is there no
black market for selling Pokemon you
know why is there no well that's what
team rocket does right yeah but they're
like why do they never get it done you
know what I mean if it was if it was the
real world they'd be pretty [__]
successful they'd be pretty good they
wouldn't be sto by a 10year old that's
for sure why did why did uh uh James
have massive boobs in that one episode
that's well some countries didn't see
that episode exactly which is part of
his coma so another another another pie
you know you know you know what I've
always wondered like why don't they eat
Pokémon well that's why cuz he can't he
can't conceptualize that it's like to
him well they have actually hinted that
in some episodes of Pokémon there's a
there's a scene I remember there's an
episode where uh like James and Jesse
are out in the ocean and they have to
eat a Magikarp yeah and they imagine
eating a Magikarp this is exactly the
scene I remember oh [__]
this suggests that perhaps they do eat
certain Pokemon yeah and in the first
episode Ash is uh struck by lightning uh
which also could put him in a coma very
well so oh he gets electrocuted by
Pikachu he does yeah they are the same
characters and themes often occur in the
series which could be seen as a
manifestation of a coma mind's limited
creativity uh they also the increasingly
Fantastical elements and powerful
characters introduced to the Seri
progresses are interpreted as a come
mind's attempt to keep the dream
interesting and engaging right right um
you know and the fact that Ash never
[__] achieves his goal ever what's up
with well he does in the final season he
does he does he does he has he that's
different DK out of the number of times
he failed at the Elite 4 he finally woke
upoke up and won the elite four but
that's it that's the end of the coma
right he gets out of it at that point so
he was in a coma until he did it is that
why they booted Ash off the Pokemon
series because he woke up from his coma
yeah cuz he he woke up from his coma and
they were like well [__] Ash 25 30 year
coma uh you know he I think at the end
of the day he's a [__] idiot uh and
he's in a [__] coma weight uh you
know like they you in a [__] lobster
right there honestly I really like this
Theory yeah this this a ton of really
this Theory makes more logical sense
than some of the stuff that happens in
Pokémon well there's also my other
favorite Pokémon theory is the the that
Pokémon used to be
people uh what what yeah there's a
there's a theory look it up the Pokémon
Used to Be Theory people um uh used to
be people Theory excuse me uh so there
so I think it's in like black and white
or one of the games like there's this
area uh where you can read a bunch of
like history books and there's some
weird ass [__] dialogue that suggests
that Pokémon used to be
humans and it's never explained why
entry in uh
I can't read that fire fire red states
that a boy with extra sensory Powers one
day woke up as a
cadabra G entry states that the Gengar
was once human takes the lives of other
humans to keep it company so there were
just like little hints like the Pokédex
entries and like certain in-game
dialogue where you're just like wait
were Pokemon humans at one point and
then they became Pokemon here here's
here's the thing how' you define a
Pokemon what what well Pokemon is short
for pocket monster so it's basically any
monster that fits on your pocket are
human Pokémon what do you
what you can't [__] tame and like
ball humans in this world so so no one's
tried I'm I'm I'm just saying I'm just
saying we've done it in the real
world I'm just saying the history of
like
Humanity uh that we've done some say
slavery is that what you're saying yes
yes I'm kind of what's Toop stop someone
trying to catch a human with a poke ball
you know uh presumably it won't work
well no one's triying oh my God you know
I'm I'm just saying what is there is
there a difference between Pokemon and
uh everything else in the Pokemon world
how do we distinguish that what is the
what is the definition you know true
maybe humans were the real Pokemon all
along another thing like why is there
like no adults there's like barely any
adult adults in the Pokémon universe and
then when they are there they all just
don't [__] do anything like what
what's the N9 to5 also there's no shot
that uh that Brock's Pokemon are real
like why does he have the shittest gym
load out like that just doesn't make
sense but only a com's mind could think
com mine would be like geod my pick you
would have to be comos you would have to
be ComEd to make up some of these gym
leader lineups even even a six-year-old
will be like n geod dude's whack bro
yeah he up with geude he's like well
hold on on guys I got an onyx and it's
like another rock what it's like you
know you have to be ComEd to to bring
some of these Pokémon here well the the
the whole idea of Pokémon started off
with Satoshi Tajiri uh growing up uh
catching insects as a child and then he
envisioned like these insects in his
childlike mind to be like more of these
like Monsters and like these Ash is
doing in this coma and Brock is his uh
repressed Sexual Energy being uh
expressed why ash in the Japanese
version his name is Satoshi it's named
after Satoshi Tajiri the Creator you
know maybe that's why uh so Satoshi
toiri might be in a coma true maybe
that's why all nurse Joys are the same
yeah why they're the same off officer J
are they can't Envision uh you know
anything else [__] yeah his his uh
Consciousness can atast go so far in
terms of rendering original characters
exactly you know there like a render run
Edition Minecraft I've reached my
character creation
limit I'm on the free trial right now
you know the jelly donuts that was a
glitch in yeah Ash's coma toasted mind
why was that why we wait hold on go back
Rock making out with joy what the [__]
is that that's not real why you got a
deviant art pick of Brock making out
with Nest Joy Brock with what the [__]
is
this
oh my God we got a thumb [__]
thumbnail that is never
happening what we're not using that as
the
thumb I okay I yeah when it comes to
like video game theories especially
Pokemon theories I I love this Theory
because it is very it could definitely
happen and the fact that no one in
Nintendo also to you to jiry himself
coming out being like no that's cap well
my favorite kind of conspiracy theories
are the ones with TV shows or whatever
just fun to be like yeah this Ed Edy
living in purgatory Theory yeah that one
sick that one sick sick I I actually I I
subscribe to this idea yeah checks out
it makes the show more fun when you
think of it like this yeah because and
also and also it brings logical answers
to some of the inconsistencies you might
find with the happy go-lucky childhood
world of Pokémon also I love these kinds
of conspiracy theories because even if
they are true even if they are false it
literally doesn't make a world of
difference
yeah like in the real world like no
there aren't going to be like a group of
people being like how [__] dare you
say this Theory it is factually
incorrect you feeding lies to the
children like no no one [__] cares
yeah you know it's cool it's a cool
Theory let's let's let's keep conspiracy
theories to this level that's my that's
my theory about uh I uh that is
definitely the most believable Theory um
not out of 10 I'll I'll give that like
an eight or n for sure thank you what's
the most what's the most what pokemon
would you eat what's the most delicious
Pokemon o
the most delicious Pokemon what's the
what's the cow Pokemon mil tank mil oh
yeah mil tank medium rare
mil you put some you put some mang
butter garlic butter on that too God
damn oh I think I think Snorlax would
probably tastes pretty I love this FU oh
can you can you imagine like the fat
content on Snorlax oh yeah oh God
Snorlax would be delicious I reckon
Chan's eggs on toast probably pretty
fire as well
Banger uh Japanese people will say way
Lord I'm just
kidding I'm just
kidding are you no I hate whale it's
disgusting about uh unhatched Togepi
unhatched Togepi it would that be kind
of
like yeah maybe did we do this on an
episode one time we were like which is
the tastiest Pokemon I swear we I think
we did dinosaurs no we did the tast
these dinosaur I swear we did Pokemon I
don't know if I'm crazy bro that's a
mandala effect I we can tank for sure
Taos movie can can can you like a bu
like a buffalo steak can are there any
Turtle Pokémon uh shelder there's a lot
of turtle Pokemon there's a bunch of
turtle squir squir
Squirtle Squirtle soup Squirtle soup
Squirtle soup I think I could I think I
could go hard I think blast toys is like
his his meat would be way too tough and
too gy squir say that again slowly his
meat would be too tough he'd be too
bricked
up I think the me can you can you can
you look up what is the tastiest Pokémon
yeah top 10 tastiest
Pokemon H it's got I mean oh the crab
would be oh crabby would be crabby
Vanilla Ice obviously yeah yeah there
Shuckle why Shuckle I agree ch's egg
looks like which Pokémon is the test
let's see oh it's ranked as well small
live just I mean it is just a [__]
tropus yeah what's what's what's yeah
what's the oh my God it's multiple Pages
it's so
cringe let's see all right let's see
number one is oh literally a cake there
literally a cake yeah that is not a real
Pokemon oh yeah Ohan fish dude chicken
and
leak chicken yeah it's a [__] isn't
it a duck is it a duck I thought fish
was a duck oh [__] it might be a duck
I don't right I don't think it's a
chicken it's not a [__] chicken wait
your whole life you thought it was a
chicken I don't know why I thought it
was a chicken wait your whole life you
far FES a chicken why did I think it was
a chicken it's a duck right yeah it's a
duck yeah that is ack got [__] webt
feet that is a duck why do I think it
was a chicken wait did your whole life
do you think it was a chicken I think
yeah why do I think it was a chicken
I'm a [__] idiot of course it's a
dock that's like say that's like saying
Psyduck is a chick isn't it based off
like some kind of um yeah cuz the
Japanese name is kigi which literally
means
duckle yeah right what the
I'm yeah well there you go it's a
chicken now it's a chicken it's chicken
have no excuse you no ex you literally
know the Japanese yeah oh God damn but
it would taste fire it would tast fire I
agree would taste fire as well very Dam
yeah leak is just banging I love leak
just like farfetched duck one of my
favorite foods in Japan is uh neima so
very good one of the best foods you can
get Japan so yeah that's the other
Theory do farfetch Yakitori would go so
hot H can I get farfetch T please Su
please Su that be all right so I think I
think we can all agree the Pokémon
theories or the video game theories are
definitely the most I prefer these
definitely definitely better let us know
down below which ones that you guys
thought were the most fun Cas you wanted
to see another cuz we have a big list
and we we thought we'd get through a lot
of them uh we got through about six six